[Musique]
c'est pour nourrir l'âme c'est pour
nourrir les souvenirs de son atelier le
monde et secondes dans le quartier
rosemont à montréal luc sénéchal veut
percer le marché en épicerie avec deux
formats de ce conte congelés prêtes à
cuire disponible pour l'instant dans
quelques haïtiens
il ya quelques entreprises aux états
unis très embryonnaire qui vend dans
plusieurs épiceries pl je me sens mais
ça se fait ça se fait congeler ça c'est
aussi bon congelés une fille une fois
cuits à la maison que si on lâche tes
frais pour présenter un produit de
qualité faits à la main avec des
ingrédients naturels sans jean
conservation ajouté et le but c'est de
démocratiser le score son aventure avec
les scones a débuté dans son café
la brume dans mes lunettes à montréal on
a réalisé le début de l'été dernier
qu'on vendait entre 1000 et 1300
secondes par mois au café donc lancé
d'immersion en avant autant ici pourquoi
on n'essaye pas d'en vendre ailleurs
au café on fait 30 saveur de ce qu'on a
à peu près en rotation on en crée des
nouvelles régulièrement environ 25
minutes au four et les secondes sont
prêts du côté de provigo l'aube las on
nous offre trois saveurs de ce consulat
marque maison délices du marché
[Musique]
les secondes salés et sucrés
gaunt en popularité ici plusieurs salons
de thé vendre les leurs les chaînes de
cafés ont emboîté le pas selon moi c'est
vrai pour lui demander eu le marché à
somain vu cet engouement leurs puits ont
décidé de de tenter par ces mêmes
marchés
tommy d'ions alias le cuisine oman se
passionne pour les scores l'extérieur
doit être très craquante donc sous la
dent savoir craquer c'est ce qu'on aime
l'intérieur voit un peu ses frites et
donc à la limite c'est qu il s'est juste
parfait avec une 14e trou ou en café et
surtout ils doivent pas être trop sucrés
mais un second temps seulement du beurre
la farine et
[Musique]
nous lui avons demandé de goûter les
secondes sucre et des chaînes
van houtte sac en coop et starbucks qui
se vendent surtout à l'heure du déjeuner
entre 3 et 5 dollars ma première
réaction quand je regarde à l'intérieur
on dirait que c'est un biscuit à la
boyne j'ai l'impression avec avec des
packs m puis il part sucré secondes et
le plus sucré et le plus sale et de
notre dégustation on est vexé lucide
vu de l'extérieur ça sent plus à
montaigne en plus ses mots à l'intérieur
mais l'extérieur écrite et du commerce
on voit si je pense pas que c'était
cabine du bar on n'a pas terminé
celui-ci très gros si tu es vraiment
pour séduire les consommateurs nord
américains qui ont du bol quelque chose
de secret des grands sur la trentaine de
secondes salés et sucrés que nous avons
analysé les valeurs nutritives varie
beaucoup chez starbucks par exemple
seconde contient jusqu'à 27 grammes de
sucre plus sucrés que certains de leurs
mâts fun les secondes sont rarement de
bonne source de fibres et même dans les
version sucrée
elles contiennent parfois beaucoup de
sodium jusqu'à 630 mg dans ces secondes
dans l'ensemble les secondes vendus en
épicerie sont aussi gras mais moins
sucrés que ceux des chaînes de café
le québec est une influence anglo saxons
depuis longtemps donc ma grand mère en
faisait cet appel des galettes à la
poudre c'est exactement la même recette
les nôtres et la nature ont eu vent de
rumeurs ou la confiture mais voilà la
recette de ce conte traditionnel est
effectivement très simple marc-andré cyr
et boulanger et on confectionne depuis
des années c'est simple à la base faire
un score beaucoup d'ingrédients de la
farine le sel sucre poudre à pâte du
beurre ouais pas mal de boire un liquide
moi j'aime utiliser le babeurre mais ça
peut être du lait ça près de la crème
il ya des gens qui mettent des heures
moi j'en mets poche mais de la future
dessus comme d'horreur mais c'est tout
j'aime mieux ajouter les saveurs par la
suite dans la forme d'une marmelade un
bar d'une campagne quelque chose que de
mettre des ingrédients carlo matiz un
peu trop dans la page
ce qu'on peut dire que c'est entre un
gâteau puis un pain c'est tellement
difficile à expliquer sait plus où il va
plus entre une pâte à taper un mot fan
tu mélanges tout mon chèque
parce qu on l approche un peu d'une
patate de d'avoir nos ingrédients assez
fois une manipulation rostren moi j'aime
d'utiliser d'europe c'est une belle
façon de défendre le bal en petits
morceaux qui s'adonnent tout des
morceaux d'une pommade la même grandeur
j'ai un cap à moba comme ça trois fois
très froid ensuite mon liquide très
froid je fabrique ma patte
une fois que tout se tient mais pas plus
le jeu va mettre sur la table c'est là
que ça commence
c'est la manipulation rendu là pour
créer créer un beau feuilletage
[Musique]
marc-andré insiste sur la simplicité le
moins de pétrissage possible pour que le
score soit faite et je me sens qu'un
euro plus c'est pareil comme ça comme on
a vraiment les chefs et compta le chef
maintenant j'ai mon phare 1 avec du soda
dans ce cas là je vois couper ma qualité
de baroudeuse je vous fait à moitié bar
moitié cheddar fort quand on enlève pas
le bar non il faut parce qu'avec juste
du fromage serait pas la même levée
comme quoi la même réaction la même
légèreté dans la pâte moi je suis pas un
fan de sa vague sont un peu trop folle
puis comme j'ai jamais un supporter de
base qu'on peut garder mais je pense non
j'ai juste un peu plus récente est dans
la tradition
ouais la reine mais mange disque on je
sais pas s'ils sont très au clair si
c'est pas un crime de lèse majesté des
phares en retoquant carré pour la
quatrième fois parce que je sache le bio
boussad au goûter coince quand on parle
de ce qu'on est sans doute et le bar ça
doit goûter la farine mais le bas
surtout
[Musique]